بعد ساعات قضاها في البحر مع رفاقه يعود
الشاب محمد محملا بما كتب الله له من رزق
فقد وضع شباكه في البحر ليخرجها ملا
باسماك ما يعرف باللحم الذي يجفف بعد ذلك
بطريقه خاصه ليحفظ لشهور عديده
اطلع
ويتعدد انواع اللخم كثير
مثل اصحاب الشرطانات واصحاب القريب يخرب
الشباك احيانا فوق الشباك يخرب الشباك
تبدا مراحل تجفيف اسماك اللخم بشق بطونها
واخراج الاحشاء منها ثم غسلها جيدا ووضع
الملح عليها بطريقه تقليديه لا يتقنها الا
اشخاص مختصون ورثوا هذه المهنه وتناقلوها
عن ابائهم واجدادهم تترك بعدها الاسماك
لتجف حتى اليوم التالي ثم تغسل مره اخرى
وتعلق بعدها على الحبال لتجف ليوم او
يومين وتكون بعدها جاهزه لنقلها الى
الاسواق وبيعها
عندما ياتي المشتري خلاص
ثلاث ايام لما هي بس ومنهم يعني يشترون
يجون من البوادي منهم يقولون من حضرموت
منهم يدنونا الى الامارات منهم الى
السعوديه
تجفيف اسماك اللخم مهنه خاصه يحترفها
الصيادون والعمال في محافظتي المهره وحضر
موت شرق اليمن ويعتمدون عليها في حياتهم
فهي توفر لهم دخلا لا باس به كما انها
تجعل الاسماك في متناول اصحاب المناطق
البعيده الذين لا تصل اليهم الاسماك
الطازجه فاللخمون مجففوا يبقى صالحا
للاستهلاك لعده اشهر
وتراوح اسعاره بين 1500 ريال يمني
والفينغرام الواحد ما يجعلها في متناول
الجميع من
ضمن الهيئه العامه للمصائد السمكيه هي
المحافظه على ديموميت هذه المهنه وهي مهنه
التجفيف الاسماك اسماك الخاصه وايضا ادخال
تقنيات باذن الله تعالى تقنيات حديثه
او تشجيع على تنميه هذه المهارات عند
الصيادين لا تخلو الموائد في المهره من
اللخم المجفف فهو داعم الحضور مع كل انواع
الاطعمه ويطهى باساليب واشكال مختلفه لا
يتقنها الا اهالي محافظتي المهره وحضرموت